Cyber security is one of the fastest
growing and most [music] respected
fields today and earning your CIS
certification can open [music] the door
to some of the highest paying and most
trusted roles in the industry. But
passing the CIS isn't just about
memorizing facts. [music] It's about
understanding how to think like a
security leader. That's exactly [music]
what this course is designed to do. I
will walk you through every domain,
simplify [music] complex topics and
share real world example that will help
you not only pass the exam but truly
master cyber security. [music]
So before we begin, like this video, hit
that subscribe button and turn on the
notification bell.
Welcome to the domain four of our CIS
course communication and network
security. And this domain also carries a
weightage of 13%. So this domain is uh
and you can say carries a significant
weightage in overall exam content. So
this domain is you can say a little bit
difficult for most of the folks due to
the networking concepts because they are
a little bit more technical. But the
good news here is that I myself have uh
have a very strong background in
computer networks and security about 15
or 16 years and my main experience is in
configuration design and troubleshooting
of computer networks including switches,
routers and firewalls. So I have a very
good concept in this domain and I hope
that after going through this video you
people will have a good understanding
and a good preparation for the CISP
exam. So let's get started.
So secure network architecture overview.
So a strong understanding of networking
principle is essential for building and
managing secure network architecture. We
are talking about the basic networking
principles and basic networking concept.
So understanding these basic concept is
essential for you to manage and secure
network architecture. So first of all we
will briefly go through the different
types of networks
and these network include the very
popular and the most common one is the
LAN local area network which connects
devices within a limited area you can
say in a building inside your home in an
office building and uh you all are uh I
hope familiar with the type of cable
that mostly used in 10 that is C 6.
Previously it was C 5 now C 6 and uh
most latest model is say K 7. So this is
the cable that is used inside the lane
and it has a maximum distance of up to
100 m. It works up to 100 m. And if if
we want to go beyond 100 m, we can
either use the optical fiber or we can
uh deploy a switch, a networking switch
and then uh re-extend the network beyond
100 m. Next is the uh main. So main is
larger than LAN. It is metropolitan area
network and it collect connects multiple
lanes across a city. So now we are going
from a single office or an organization
to a complete city. And an example of a
man is a citywide uh Wi-Fi.
It can also be uh a wide network. So uh
sometime known as a metro Ethernet or uh
ME
network which is uh connects different
organization or different offices in a
city through OFC network. So this is
also an example of main. Next is the
largest network and that is the vanwide
area network which covers large
geographical areas
uh such as it connects cities or even
countries and the most popular example
and the largest one is the internet. Pen
is the you can say the smallest network
type and is personal area network which
connect devices in a very close range
such as uh 10 yards and one example of
pen is the Bluetooth.
So internet as we studied it is the
global way connecting systems worldwide
and it is the public web such as you
people now are watching this video on
the internet you are connected from all
over the world watching this video.
Internet is an internal organizational
network which is within a specific
organization as the name indicate it is
intra. So inter is large concept between
countries and all over the world. Intra
is within intra or within an
organization such as a company internal
network or portal. Externate is shared
network between an organization and
external partners such as vendor and
customer access portal.
Now coming over to OSI and TCP IP models
overview. So the purpose of networking
model why we have developed these models
it is to define standards for network
communication and interoperatability
between different protocol different
devices and different vendors
application
and it uses a layered approach to
simplify design and enhance security as
we will study different layers in OSI
model uh couple of moment.
It enables interoperability among
vendors and systems. Support modular
engineering, troubleshooting and product
development and models are basically
guidelines not strict requirements.
So now coming on to an overview of OSI
and TCP IP model. So OSI reference model
that is ISO it is defined in the ISO
7498-1
and it has seven layers. So we were
starting from the top most layer that is
layer 7 and it is the application layer
and its function is that it inter it uh
gives the interface for user
applications ensure readable data
exchange and the data unit or protocol
data unit that is used at this layer is
known as simply as data. Now examples of
protocols used at this layer are popular
protocol HTTP secure version of HT HTTPS
file transfer protocol SQL mail transfer
protocol and other multiple protocol.
Next layer layer six is the presentation
layer where data formatting encryption
and compression takes place. Again the
PDU at this layer is known as data and
example of protocol at this layer are
TLS, transport layer, security, secure
circuit layer and mine.
Layer five is the session layer which
manages and maintains communication
sessions and PDU again know is known as
data at this layer. An examples of
protocol at this layer includes RPC,
remote procedure call, SMB and NFS.
And SMB is uh file file transfer uh is
uh SMB stands for server message block
and NFS is again file system, network
file system. Layer four is the popular
transport layer and it function is
reliable delivery of data flow control
and error checking and PDU or data unit
at this layer is known as segment and
popular protocol at this layer are TCP
transmission control protocol and UCP
uh uh user datagramgram protocol
or unit datagramgram protocol
it So I'm correct. So layer three is the
network layer and here the logical
addressing and routing takes place.
Logical addressing takes place through
IP addresses
and the PDU at this layer is known as
packard and popload protocol at this
layer are IP, ICMP, OPF and IPSC. So OPF
is the dynamic routing protocol ICMP.
You all people must know it is used for
troubleshooting of networks such as
ping. IP is the popular uh protocol
which is used for logical addressing
routing and IPAC is used as a security
on this layer also known as IP security.
Layer two is the data link uh layer
which is uh does the physical addressing
and physical addressing is done through
MAC logical through IP address physical
through MAC and F frame transmission
takes place at this layer. So the PDU at
this layer is known as frame. And
examples of protocol at this concept and
protocol at this layer are Ethernet
vain uh function as this layer and PM
relay also takes place at this
and the layer number one is known as the
physical layer which is where the
transmission of raw based via cable or
through wireless media takes place and
the PU at this layer is known bits and
byes and examples of protocol at this
layer or USB, Bluetooth and 10b.
So what is the difference or the
comparison between the OSI model and TCP
IP model? So OSI model is a conceptual
framework describing how data moves
through a network
of seven layers. TCP IP model is the
practical suit of communication protocol
used on the internet. So this is a
conceptual model OSI model. It was
developed but it was not practically
used. The practically used model is the
TCP IP model which has less layer than
we will study in a while that how many
layers has TCP IP model. So the general
rule is that layer when we talk about
layers we are talking about the OSI
model layers and we when we talk about
protocol we mainly refer to the TCP IP
model.
So this is the these are the layers of
the TCP IP model. In OSI model we have
seven seven layers and in TCP IP model
we have four layers and these layers are
application layer at the top then
transport internet and network. So
application layer is now layer four. It
handles high level protocols like HTTP,
FTP, SMTP and DNS. Number two is the uh
transport layer which is layer three.
Here it is layer three and it manages
end to end communication. And as we
studied the popular protocol at this
layer are TCP for reliability and UDP is
for uh speed where data transmission uh
is needed in speed but reliability is uh
not as essential as speed of
transmission.
At layer two, we have the internet layer
which handles addressing as we studied
logical addressing through IP
addressing, routing and packet
forwarding which takes place through IP
and for troubleshooting or error
checking you have ICMP
and the uh layer number one is the
network access layer which defines
physical transmission through Ethernet,
Wi-Fi, address resolution protocol and
MAC. addressing.
So now coming over to a comparison of
the TCP IP and uh OSI model. So as we
can see in this diagram, the upper three
layer of OSI they combine and make the
application layer in the PIB. The
transport layer similarly corresponds to
the transport layer. transport layer in
both these model network layer to
network layer and the you can say the
first two layers the layer 1 and layer
two in OSI model basically corresponds
to the network access layer. So the
similarities between these two are that
both are layered model for network
communication both both use
encapsulation and the encapsulation.
So when data uh moves let's suppose
downwards from application to transport
data is capsulated and when it moves
then uh upward
let's suppose it is received at the
opposite side and observed data then
encapsulated
decapsulated.
So this is what we mean by encapsulation
encapsulation. Encapsulation means that
at each layer uh each layer adds it its
own header. For example, at transport
layer the port numbers are added. At
network layer, IP addresses are added at
data link MAC addresses and so on. The
difference is that TCP IP has four
layers while OSI has seven layer. TCP IP
is more practical rather it is
practically used and it is the only
model that is widely used while OSI is
theoretical. TCP IP combine the
presentation and session layers into the
application layer as well as the
application layer.
So again now coming over to uh each
layer of the TCP IP and their
corresponding uh attacks that takes
place at each layer. So as we studied
the layer one is the physical layer
which handles transmission and reception
of raw data across a medium. It converts
digital bits into electrical, optical or
radio signals. And so why these three
different types of signal? Because if
the uh communication is taking place in
a lane through K 6, let's suppose if the
media is K 6 or copper cable,
the bits are converted into or you can
electrical uh signals. If it is
uh you can say the cable is OFC it is
converted into optical signal and if it
is wireless it is connected into radio
signal. So it defines network topology
such as ring bus star and mesh and
examples of physical layer concept
include the internet cables Bluetooth
and USB. What are some attacks that
takes place at layer one? The first one
is the sniffing which is capturing the
signals or cables or wireless travel.
For example, if you are simply listening
to the Wi-Fi or wireless traffic, you
are capturing the medium traffic through
sniffing and this takes place at layer
one interference.
So introducing noise to disrupt
communication. So for example, if the
Wi-Fi work is working at 2.4 GHz,
you
uh introduce signals in this particular
spectrum, the interference will be
introduced into Wi-Fi signal and traffic
or the signals will be weakened and
speed will be low and overall the
efficiency of network will be disrupted.
Cable damage. So physically cutting or
disconnecting cables and similarly
denied of service by jamming or
overloading physical channel. So
physical channel may be the as we said
the Wi-Fi channel you can uh someone can
jam them or they can also jam the
physical cables by cutting them or by
overloading them through other means.
Again layer two is the data link layer
where transfer of data takes place
between nodes over the physical link. It
converts bits into frames for reliable
node to node communication. It provides
error detection
alerts and flow control and it defines
how devices connect such as bus ring
topology etc. And it switches. So the
switches which are the network devices
they basically operate at this layer or
layer two.
So the MAC address is the concept that
work at this layer. It uses uh 48 bit
hexadimal identifier for each wise. So
the format of the MAC address is uh this
one or this one. some vendor or some uh
time it is the
is
you can say hexadimal number are
separated through column and somewhere
through dashes.
So the first prefix of 48 bits is
basically the manufacturer ID which is
assigned by the triple e we are talking
about these first
24 bits. So the each octed is 8 bit. So
8 8 and 8 3 into 8 24 and the suffix
that is the last 24 bits. These S stands
for suffix. These basically these are
the devices serial number and these
uniquely identify each device. So each
laptop, each PC, each you can say router
in which they have unique serial number
known as the MAC address and it is
identified by this. So let's suppose if
we have Cisco networking devices they
all will have the same first 24 bits
these that will identify the device as
the Cisco while the last three octet
they will vary which will be unique
identifier for each device. For example
this is a MAC address. So it is the uh
belongs to link system and this can be
identified through these
first 24 bits.
Layer two attacks are max spooping and
are poisoning. So in these attacks
attackers forge our request and replies
to impersonate as another device and
they redirect traffic to attackers
system and this type of attacks enables
man in the middle attack and session
hijacking.
Layer three is the network layer which
provides routing and forwarding. So
packets travel from source to
destination. So it receives service
requests from transport that is layer
four and issues request to layer two
that is data link and the function of
network as we already studied these are
logical addressing to IP addresses
routing packet fragment segmentation
reassembly forwarding and delivery
error reporting and it supports con
connection orient connection oriented
and connectionless
protocol. So it supports both type of
protocol.
Important concepts in layer 3 network
layer are logical addressing or
basically the IP addresses which is the
host logical address uh host logical
location for example 192 168
1. This may be an address of a host and
it shows that this host is located at
this logical location. Gateway routers
forward packets between segmented
networks. That is the gateway or router
basically transfer traffic from the
internet
from internal company network to the
outer that is internet. So fragmentation
uh means splitting large packets into
allowable sizes without losing integrity
and IPSC is a set of protocol for
securing IP traffic through VPNs and
encryption.
Common network layer uh protocols
includes the IP protocol which is used
for addressing and routing and have two
version of this IPv4 and IPv6.
BGP is the border gateway protocol which
is a path vector routing between
autonomous systems.
EGP we have two types of BGP. One is
EBGP which is between autonomous systems
and IBGP is within an autonomous system.
So E you can say it stand for external
and I is for internal. So, IBGP works
within uh an autonomous system which you
can say is managed or controlled by uh
same organization.
So, use a sense uses a sense keeps
multiple paths in uh RI and chooses path
minimizing autonomous system hubs. OPF
is another dynamic routing protocol. OPF
is open sort test path first. It is a
link state interior gateway protocol for
fast convergence and scalability and it
builds topology and recomputes routes
quickly
and we have the uh uh it works at uh
IPv4 uses IPv4 and IPv6
in OPFV version 3. So it encapsulate
directly in IP protocol
in it in it is encapsulated directly in
IP
and uh it uh it is known as protocol 89
inside the IP you can say header. So RIP
[clears throat] is another dynamic
routing protocol. It stands for routing
information protocol. It is a distance
vector and it uses hop count. It works
up to maximum 15 hops. It is simple and
suitable for small networks and it
implement implements split horizon route
poisoning hold down timer and uses UTP
port 520 for operation.
So RIPG uses port
521 for IPv6. RIPG say it is the latest
or next generation
RIP which uses port uh 521 on IPv6.
So common network layer protocol again
another one is ICMP internet control
message protocol which is used for
troubleshooting and error messages such
as ping and trace route and common
message types are eco request reply
destination unreachable time exceeded
and correct. Another network layer
protocol is IGMP which is internet group
management protocol and manages IP4
multiccast group membership is one to
many and IPv6 basically uses MLDD which
is part of version 6.
So now coming over to some layer three
attack vectors. The first one is IP
spoofing and address for the attacker
forges source IP addresses to
distinguish origin or redirect traffic.
Next is the man in the middle attack
which is via root route manipulation or
malicious routing updates. Then we have
the denial of service and distributed
denial of service attack which is
overwhel overwhelming the network
resources to deny service to legitimate
users. Then we have routing protocol
attacks for example BGP hijacks
falsified route advertisement or OPF
link state manipulation
and lastly we have reconnaissance using
IC ping and trace route to map networks
for later attacks.
Next we have the layer 4 transport layer
and its purpose and key function include
that it provides end to end
communication and reliable data
transport between host. It shields upper
layers that is layer 5 to 7 from lower
layer complexity.
It manages segmentation, flow control,
multiplexing, error detection and
recovery. It establishes and maintains
and terminates virtual circuits for data
transmission.
Core functions again include flow
control which prevents sender from
overwhelming the multiplexing is that it
allows multiple application to share the
same physical link. Virtual circuit is
logical connections for managing
sessions between host and error checking
and recovery. basically detects
transmission errors and retransmit lost
data.
The key protocol at this layer layer
four or transmission control protocol
TCP which is a connection oriented
protocol. It ensures reliable delivery
through sequencing and acknowledgements.
It uses three-way handshake to establish
connection and the three-way handshake
is first packet is send then we have
seen egg and third is egg. So it
guarantees delivery detects errors and
retransmit last packets. It is slower
due to overhead but ensures accuracy. It
is used by protocols such as HTTP,
HTTPS, FTP, SSH and SMTP.
So is a concept which is the combination
of IP address and port. For example, the
IP address 1921 said 100.10 column 22.
This is known as socket.
So this is how the three-way handshake
takes place. So the client first sends
the sin packard, the server responds
with a sin actard and lastly the client
responds with egg packers and this way
threeway handshake is established.
The next popular protocol at this layer
is user datagramgram protocol or UDP. So
it is connectionless, lightweight and
fast which is best effort delivery.
So this protocol gives no sequencing of
flow control or retransmission as
opposed to TCP. So it is ideal for
realtime data where speed is
greatly required than reliability
and it is used by DNS, DHCP, SNMP, voice
or IP and video audio streaming as well
as the of thing devices.
So datagram is the basic data unit in
this connectionless transmission.
So some layer four attack vectors
include the sin flood attack which is
the denial of service attack where the
target is flooded with incomplete TCP
handshakes
which exhaust the resources of the
target or the server. Portbased attacks
are trojan and malware that exploits
open TCP and UDP ports. And session
hijacking is where attacker intercepts
or takes over active TCP sessions.
So this is how the you can say the send
flood attacks or you can say act flood
attacks or denial of server attack takes
place. We have the server. This is the
attacker which overwhelmed the server
with these uh forged acts.
And when the legitimate user try to
connect with the server, it connection
request is denied because the server is
all already very busy or overwhelmed by
these packers.
Layer five that is session layer. So the
purpose and responsibility of this layer
are that it manages logical and
persistent connections that is session
application or different host. It
establishes coordinates and terminates
dialogues between local and remote
applications. It facilitates higher
level interactions for example RPCs. So
application processes can request
receive services across the network.
The modes of operation on session layer
are full duplex which is a two-way
simultaneous communication. So both the
endpoints send and view data at the same
time or at once. Half duplex is two-way
but only one direction at a time takes
place. So only one device sends the
data, the next receives it and then the
other one sends the data and
second device receives it. So at a time
only one can send both devices cannot
send the data at the same time. Simplex
is the oneway communication where only
sender sends the data and viewer only
such as you can say your television your
TV uh when connected to cable network is
simplex because it only receives
signals and displays it. It does not
send something back.
So layer five attack vectors include
session authentication compromise. So in
this attackers breaks session setup or
authentication and impersonates
a participants weak cryptographic
session. So deprecated or weak SSLTS
versions allow session hijacks or
downgrade attacks protocol specific
explers. So vulnerabilities,
net bios, NFS or other sessionation
such as denial of service and privilege
escalation, session hijacking and replay
also takes place at layer five which is
stealing on reusing session tokens to
impersonate an active user.
Layer six is the presentation layer. So
where which translates here uh
translation takes place between lower
layer and the application layer. It
handles data formatting, compression and
encryption and shows compatibility
between different systems. Key function
includes that it converts data into
application readable formats. It uses
standard data formats such as in for
image, audio and video. So it applies
compression for example JPEG and PEG and
it performs encryption and encryption
for example SSL and through TLS.
So encryption notes is that encryption
and decryption may occur at multiple
layers. SSL generally operates at the
presentation layer while TLS shares
functionality with the session and
presentation layers.
So layer six attack vectors include
target encryption and decryption
mechanisms, exploit weaknesses in
cryptographic algorithms, use
cryptonalytic technique to break
encryption and attack poorly implemented
or outdated cryptography.
Layer seven or last layer is the
application layer where which is the
highest layer of the OSI model and
closest to the end user. It provides
network access for software applications
and acts as an interface between the
user and the network and facilitates
communication between applications
across the network. Key function include
that uh this layer identifies
communication partner. It determines
resource availability, synchronizes
communication session and it support
protocols such as HTTP, FTP, SMTP, TNET
and SNMP. It enables applications like
web browsers such as Chrome, Safari,
Firefox to function.
So layer seven attack vectors are
exploitation of application layer
protocol weaknesses such as HTTP, FTP,
SMTP and SMTP. Web- based attacks takes
place at this layer such as HT flooding,
input validation attacks, SQL injection
and cross-sight scripting. User
interface attacks basically targets end
user interactions authentication
weaknesses such as weak as you reuse
passwords poor password management also
takes place in this layer.
Now coming over to our next topic which
is IP addressing uh or internet protocol
networking.
So IP is the core protocol of the
internet and it operates at network
layer in OSI model and internet layer at
TCP IP
model and it enables data transmission
across network boundaries. It has two
main version IP4 IPv6.
IPv6 is the latest and uh it is uh
gradually replaces the folder IPv4.
So now coming over to internet protocol
version 4 that is IPv4 it uses 32bit IP
addresses an example of this is 172 8.
So each of these octat is 8 bit. So 8 we
have four octad. So 8 into 4 is equal to
32. So it is 32 bit. And addresses are
written as four decimal octed. And these
arct ranges from 0 to 255.
So if you see something like this 299.
So this address is ROM for this uh octet
range is up to 255 from 0 to 255.
So the IP addresses are divided into
classes. So class we have class A B C
which are for general use
used by the networks and given to host.
Class D is for multiple multiccasting
and class E is for experimental use.
So IPv4 provides approximately 4 billion
unique IP addresses. So originally when
uh internet was new devices were very
few it was sufficient but now these
addresses are limited due to the growth
of internet and internet of thing
devices and other connected devices.
So these are the classes of IP before we
have class A. So the first octet as we
saw in the previous example it ranges
from 1 up to 1 to 6. So when you see any
IP address such as 10
if the first octed is from 1 to 1 to 6
it is class A. So this address is
class A because the first octed is 10.
Maximum number of host per network are
this 167214
the huge number of host in a single
network and we have a total number of 1
to8 networks class B is the first octed
in this class ranges from 1 to 8 uh from
1 to 82 up to 191. So if you see an IP
address of what let's suppose 13510.1
then it means this address belongs to
class B and we have 65,535
number of host in class B network and
have 16,384
number of networks in this class. Then
we have class C
and class C first range is from 192 up
to 223 to be the popular IP address
addresses such as 192 168 and
1.
This belongs to class C. So it has the
maximum number of host of 254 in this uh
class. And we have these number of
networks inside class C. Class D has the
first octet range of 2 to 4 up to 239.
And since this is used for
multiccasting, so we don't have uh
number of host per network. Similarly,
this is number of network is also not
applicable. And this class E first
octate range is from 240 up to 255.
So this is again reserved
IP range. So if you see something uh IP
address starting from let's suppose 2 4
5 it belongs to class E and
experimental.
So let me clean the screen. So
transition from IPv6 from IPv4 to IPv6.
So IPv6 is the long-term solution for IP
address exhaustion. Network address
translation orn net basically currently
extends IPv4 visibility. How does this
extend IPv4 visibility
in this matter? So uh these are the
private IP addresses that are used
inside you can say lane or your local
private network and then this all these
devices can talk to the internet or
external network or a single IP address
through a process known as net or
network address translation.
So each of these devices when they want
to talk to external world or internet
this single devices a single IP address
is used by all these devices and this is
uh IP addresses are translated by the
net server.
So you can say now that all these
addresses can now used by anyone else
where we have may have another company.
Let's suppose this is company A, company
B. So this company can again use these
uh all these addresses and then they
will have their own unique
public IP address to which all these
devices will talk to the internet. So in
this way we can reuse the uh private IP
addresses through netting.
So it translates the local IP address to
the global or public IP address. It
operates at the network layer or layer
3. It is implemented inside firewalls,
routers and gateways and proxies. So
originally it was designed to extend
IPv4 address usage but now it is
considered a legacy technology with both
pros and cons. Pros is that again it
makes your these internal devices
invisible only your uh public IP address
is visible. Cons is that it interferes
with some type of uh traffics
and uh it is you can say uh difficult to
troubleshoot and to implement as well.
The advantages of net are that it
connects a private network to the
internet using a single or few public IP
addresses. It uses private ranges which
we are defined in RFC 1918 and these
ranges are n if I write them
particularly 10 0 0/8
12 and 1 192 168
16. So it hides the internal IP
structure and network topography. As I
said,
it prevents direct access from the
internet to your internal devices. It
allows outbound connection from private
network and ensures return traffic. It
enhances security by obscuring internal
IPs from the attackers. And it is cost
effective because it conserve limited
public IPv4
addressing.
Disadvantages of network address
translation include that it is a
temporary solution and lacks an official
IE standard. It is inconsistent
implication implementation across
devices. So it is implemented in
multiple ways across different devices.
It breaks peer-to-peer communication and
so workarounds are done to tackle this
issue. For example, Skype uses super
nodes to bypass net or network address
translation issues and conflicts with IP
sec integrity checks hash uh mismatch.
It is solved using the net d or net
reversal and it is unnecessary for IPv6
which provides a vastly large address
space. So it is no longer used in IPv6.
The key takeaway are that Net played a
vital role prolonging IPv4 usability and
enhancing network privacy. But with the
adoption of IPv6, its necessity is
diminishing.
Now coming over to our next IP protocol
which is IP protocol version 6, IPv6. So
this previous one IPv4 used 32bit. It
uses 1 to 8 bit IP addresses. It is
written in hexadesimal format separated
by columns. So IPv4 was used in decimal.
This one is written in hexa decimal
format such as this one. It is divided
in two parts. 64bit is the network
prefix and 64bit is interface
identifier. So both these may be 1 to8
bit address. It supports 1028 times more
addresses than IP v4. So it supports way
more addresses as compared to IPv4. So
it enhances addressing routing and
scalability.
The benefits of IPv6 are that it has
scoped addresses that it adds security
and access control built-in. It enables
admins to group allow or deny access to
services. It has the auto configuration
features which eliminates the need for
DHCP and net and each device can self
assign a public IP address. quality of
service. It improves priority values for
efficient effect management. It has a
massive address space which ensures
future expansion of connected devices.
So adoption and challenges of IPv6. So
it was created by the IETF to solve the
IPv4 address exhaustion. It is supported
by most modern operating systems since
2000. It adoption remains slow due to
upgrade cost of IPv6 capable devices,
satisfactory performance of existing
IPv4,
limited immediate return on investment
for many organization. So early adopter
or large enterprises, research labs and
universities.
So now coming over to network attack. So
many networking protocols were developed
before security was a priority. So as a
result vulnerabilities still exist in
network host. Even hardened system can
be attacked through network services.
Security in networking was often an
afterthought though modern revision aim
to prove it.
Understanding network vulnerabilities.
So network protocol define how host
communicate across different layers.
Each OSI layer can be targeted by
specific attack vectors.
The knowledge of these layers helps
security professional identify and
defend against attacks.
So now coming out to different attacks
and first one is the distributed denial
of service attack.
So DOS is flooding a target system with
excessive traffic to make it unavailable
for the legitimate users. So attackers
basically uses brute force traffic.
floods. For example, UDB packets send
floods as we studied in our previous
slides from multiple sources. And
commonly it this are these type of
attacks are launched through infected
internet of thing devices and
compromised machines also known as
zombies
or sometime
botn nets.
The mechanism is that a botnet or
network of hijack system sends massive
simultaneous request. Each device
contributes minimal traffic but
collectively overwhelm the target. The
goal is to consume bandwidth or server
resources causing system failure.
So sin flooding attack which takes at
transport layer layer four which is a
type of the DOS or deny of service
attacks. So this is how it work. It
exploits the TCP 3-way handshake.
Attackers send a flood of sin packets
but never complete the handshake with
management. Victim system keeps half
open connection which exhausts the
system resources. it. This type of
attack is also known as half open
attack. The impact is that the server
becomes unresponsive to legitimate
users. It is common even today respired
existing patient.
The mitigation techniques include to
increase the backlog Q so allows more
half open connection which requires more
memory and may impact performance to
recycle oldest half open connections to
uses a first in first out that is FIFO
strategy to override the oldest request
and helps maintain service availability
for legitimate users.
Next is the man-in-the-middle attacks
which which are the attacks in which
attackers intercept, replace and
possibly alters communication with two
parties. Sender and receiver believe
they have a direct and private
connection although there is some
someone in between them. Types of an
example of many the middle attack
include dropping where attacker
passively listens while relaying
messages. Impersonation is where
attacker circumvents authentication and
presents as a legitimate endpoint.
Packet sniffing or passive
man-in-the-middle attack captures
unencrypted traffic to harvest
credentials, IP addresses, and data. And
hijacking or active man-in-the-middle
attack is where attackers steal or
inject session tokens, cookies to assume
a user's session.
So how does the man in the middle
attacks work? So attackers position
between endp points that is network
sniffing
to our spoofing or calling rug access
point or proxy. The attacker then
intercepts peckers optionally modifies
payload and forwards them to the
destination. The victims remains unaware
unless authentication or temper checks
fail.
Detection or indicators of these attacks
are unexpected latency or response time
anomalies versus baseline, TLS or HTTPS
warning or certificate mismatches
browser and unusual session behavior
such as duplicate session or sudden
session termination.
Prevention and mitigation of men in the
middle attacks include strong
authentication
which include mutual TLS and X509
certificates issued by trusted
certification authorities encryption end
to end
TLS and HTTPS and modern cipher suits
able disable the deprecated SSL
certificate pinning and HSTS
which reduce risk forge certificates and
downgrade attacks. Temper detection so
monitor latency integrity checks and
message hashes network control. So
disable promiscuous ports,
use secure Wi-Fi protocol which is WPA2
and three and isolate untrusted network,
monitor and alerting. So detect unusual
session patterns, repeated authorization
or authentic failures or certificate
anomalies. Our next attack type is
packet sniffing.
So there is a legitimate use of packet
sniffing in network troubleshooting,
performance monitoring and protocol
analysis. Such as an example of a tool
that can be used for network
troubleshooting using packet snip is
wire shark
which captures packets on a live wire
and then it can be used for network
troubleshooting. On the other hand, the
malicious use of pecker sniffing is when
passive capture of clear text credential
tokens, payment data and configuration
info is done with the intent of using
this info maliciously. Reconnaissance to
identify deprecated ciphers, active
directory server or exploitable
services.
The mitigation of packet sniffing
include inricing encrypting the
sensitive traffic through TLS, SSH and
IPAC
to limit the administrative access to
network tabs and monitoring tools.
Network tabs means to capture network
data through network tabs. apps is for
example if we have this network switch
and we are having all type of data
coming and going through different ports
where different clients are connected.
If we take one port,
use this as a tab and we configure this
uh network device this switch or router
such that all the inout data is copied
to this port. So all the data can then
be analyzed
uh on this port and this capture is
known as network tab.
Use port security 802.1x.
This is in fact the port security and
network segmentation.
Next is the hijacking attacks. So in
hijacking attacks, attackers exploit
active sessions by stealing or forging
session identifiers such as cookies and
tokens
and they can run parallel sessions or
terminate the victim's session. So
common vectors in hijacking attacks
include sniff session cookies or
unencrypted channels, cross-ite
scripting to excfiltrate tokens and
session fixation or replay attacks.
Mitigation include using secure HTTP
only same side cookie flags and start
session lifetimes. Enforce HTTPS only
cookies and token binding where possible
and implementing multiffactor or MFA
authentication and anomni based session
monitoring.
Our next topic is MITER attack
framework. So MITER framework was
developed by MITER organization which is
a US nonprofit research organization and
the purpose of this framework was to
provide a comprehensive knowledge base
of real world adversary tactics and
techniques. It focuses on how the
attackers operate the attackers behavior
goals and attack steps and it is used in
by security professional to develop
threat models analyze instance and pro
defenses.
So it is organized by tactics that is
the attacker attacks goal and techniques
the methods used to achieve those goals
and it is a global resource and freely
accessible at this uh address site.
So it is used for threat detection, red
teaming, instant response and security
assessment.
So now coming over to some secure
protocols that are secure by nature and
that can be used inside your
organization and should be used.
So the purpose of secure protocol is to
provide secure communication and
authentication over networks. Some
common secure protocols include SSH,
TLS, Gerberos, IPSC and IKE.
We will study these uh in coming
upcoming slides. First one is the SSH.
So SSH replaces the insecure Tnet
protocol. Tnet used clear text data when
communicating with the remote server.
SSH uses encrypted data. So function is
that it enables secure encrypted
communication or TCP. It is a based on
client server model for remote login and
command executions. So it prevents
session hijacking dropping and men in
the middle attack because the session is
encrypted.
Versions are SSH1 which is outdated and
secure and should not be used.
SSH2 has improved security and
efficiency against spoofing and
man-in-the-middle attacks. The use cases
include securely manage servers, network
devices and file transfer through SCP
and SAFTP. So both of these also use
SSH.
Next secure protocol is the transport
layer security TLS. So the purpose of
TLS is to provide secure web
communication. TLS has replaced the SSL
which was the main protocol for secure
web traffic. Now TLS is main protocol.
So SSL is legacy session oriented
protocol which was once used for web,
email, FTP and channel
and SSL status is deprecated due to
known vulnerabilities. So now we should
use TLS instead. So TLS improvements
include stronger authentication
encryption. It prevents tampering,
spoofing and dropping.
Another secure
rather the TLS features include that it
supports secure client server
communication or insecure networks. It
enables one-way authentication via
digital certificates. It also enables
two-way authentication using mutual
certificate exchange. Two-way means
authentication of both the client as
well as the server. It operates
typically as the initial TCP payload
securing higher layer protocols. It can
also operate at network layer or layer 3
as openVPN. It supports encryption for
both UDP and SIP connection. SIP is the
session initiating protocol and primary
it is the primary mechanism for secure
e-commerce sessions.
The key advantage of TLS is that no VPN
client is required. When we use the
browser for secure browsing, we are
using uh TLS and we don't use any VPN
client. So TLS can create ondemand
encrypted tunnels via the web browser
for remote access without the need of
any client.
Next is so again this is the same
slide. So our next pure protocol is the
internet protocol security IP stack. So
the purpose IP sec is to provide card
confidentiality integrity and
authentication for IP network data. It
secures communication between systems by
encrypting and authenticating IP
packets.
So IP6 security services include
authentication header known as a which
authenticates the sender of the data and
it detects data modification during
transmission. So it is used for you can
say authentication as well as integrity.
As the name indicates this protocol
mainly gives us the authentication and
integrity of data. on the other hand
encapsulation security payload. It
authenticates the sender as well as it
encrypts the data for card
confidentiality. So this is the main
difference between uh these two
protocol. ESP basically provides
the confidentiality
as well as authentication while the AH
does not provide conf confidentiality.
It only provides integrity and
authentication. Security aspirations are
the bundles of shared key and parameter
which are required for authentication
header and our encryation security
payload protocol. It defines how to
system will secure the traffic.
So IPSAC has two modes. First one is the
transport mode which encrypts and
authenticates only the IP payload or you
can say the data portion without the
header. It is used for end to end secure
communication. The second mode is the
tunnel mode which encrypts and
authenticates the entire
IP packard that is header as well as
data. It encapsulate encap encapsulates
it in a new IP packard. So internal mode
the IP sec encapsulate the whole IP
packard inside a new IP packard or new
IP header. It is commonly used for VPN
between networks or gateways. Gateway
means that this one is used for
VPN between you can say firewall to
firewall while this one can be used you
can say from client to server.
So another important concept in IPSAC is
the internet key exchange or IKE which
is used inside IPSAC and the purpose of
Ike is to establish a secure
authenticated channel between two
entities for IPSAC.
It uses the X509 PKI certificates for
authentication
and Deffy Helman Merkel key exchange for
shared secret creation. Versions of IKE
include Ike version 1 which is was the
original version and less secure. I
version two is the enhanced version
addressing configuration and security
flaw. Vulnerabilities of IP sec or I you
can say offline dictionary attack. So to
avoid this attack you need to use strong
and high and propy passwords.
downgrade attacks forcing I version one
from I version two. So segment system
using I1 and I2 to prevent mixing
virtual local area network or VLAN. So
the purpose of VLAN is that VLAN
isolates network traffic into separate
broadcast domains. It uses ILE E 802.1Q
tagging to assign VLAN ids to Ethernet
frames
and the access ports in vain you carries
untagged traffic and belongs to a single
VN while the trunk ports carries tagged
traffic and it can be used to carry
multiple van traffic. So native vain is
the unteed vain on transport avoid. So
you should avoid using the vain one as
the native van.
The benefits of vain are that it reduces
broadcast traffic. It improves security
and segmentation and enhances network
manageability and performance.
Some common VLAN attacks and mitigation.
First one is the VLAN hopping also known
as double tagging. So attacker adds two
VLAN tags. First switch removes the
outer tag. Second switch forwards frame
using the inner tag and attacker gains
access to the target VLAN.
Mitigation of this attack includes
double auto trunking or DTP. Change
native VLAN to an unused one, not the
VLAN ID one. As we study, we should not
use V ID1 for native V. Configure all
ports as access ports unless trunking is
required. Disable unused ports and
assign to an unused
VLAN.
Use port security 802.1x authentication
VLAN access control list. Avoid default
VLAN one and limit trunk ports. Pure
management access with SSH and logging.
Our next topic is scattera and scattera
is supervisory control and data
acquisition.
So it is architecture that uses
computers to monitor and control
industrial processes.
Industries using starta include power
generation and transmission, oil and gas
pipelines, water and waste water
management, manufacturing and utility.
These are some of the industries that
use SCADA systems. So the protocol used
by SCADA is DNP3 or distributed network
protocol 3.
So DNP3 or distributed network protocol
3 is a legacy open standard protocol
used in utility industries. It enables
data transfer and control commands and
can be encapsulated over TCP IP for
connectivity.
What are some scarda security risk and
mitigations? So security risk inside
scattera include encapsulation for DNP3
or TCP IP. So this increases exposure to
networkbased attacks. So if you use TCP
IP, you are exposed to the
vulnerabilities and attacks that are
specifically used against TCP IP stacks.
When in the middle attacks can intercept
and alter control signals weak or no
encryption AC designs integration with
office network and internet increases
the vulnerability and exposure target
for nation state or critical
infrastructure attacks.
What are some mitigation strategy
against
security risks? So these include network
segmentation. Always isolate scard off
from corporate and internet networks.
Prevent firewall and intrusion detection
and prevention system for scard traffic.
Use VPN and strong encryption for remote
access. Apply strict access controls and
authentication.
Regular patching and firmware updates.
Continuous monitoring for abnormal
activity.
So what are converge protocol? So
converge protocol basically merges
specialtity or propriety protocol with
standard protocol. For example, TCP IP.
This reduces reliance on costly
proprietary hardware and enhances
performance depending on protocol type.
So the purpose of converge protocol is
that they enable integration of data
storage and bias over a single network
structure.
So now coming over to some common
convage protocol and the first one is
fiber channel or Ethernet or FC. So this
combines fiber channel with Ethernet
using Ethernet frame. It supports SAN
and NAS storage up to 256 GB per second
and works over copper or fiber cable. So
SAN is storage area network and NAS is
network attached storage. Key benefits
of FCE include that it reduces cost by
using Ethernet instead of dedicated
fiber network. It enables highspeed data
storage. Next is the internet small
computer system interface or IC scuzzi.
So it transmits SCSI or SCSI commands
over IP networks and acts as a virtual
SATA or SCSI cable for remote storage.
Benefit is that it is low cost
alternative to fiber channel and
supports remote storage access or
standard IP.
Next is the multi-protocol label
switching or MLS. So this routes data
using start labels instead of IP
addresses. Separates between OSI layer 2
and three. It gives us faster data
transfer. supports multiple network
types such as ATM, DSL and sonnet.
Last one is the vice or or IP or vice or
internet protocol. So this encapsulates
vice and multimedia communication or IP
network.
It is cost effective telephoneony
integrates easily with existing data
network. For example, when you are
calling someone over your WhatsApp or
when we were using
Skype. So these are are examples of W.
An important topic is micro
segmentation. So micro segmentation
basically divides a network into smaller
and isolated zones to protect the
sources individually. This requires
reauthentication
when accessing resources across zones
and enable policies that limit traffic
between segments and supports zero trust
architecture principle. Benefits of
micro segmentation include that it
reduce the attack surface. It gives us
simplified policy management as network
visibility
and recognized by key organization. So
NIST
it is recognized by NIST in zero trust
guidance of August 2020 and NISA which
has in multiple application publication
since 2020.
Our next topic is SDN softwaredefined
networking.
SDN is a centralized network management
approach enabling control across
vendors, applications and technologies.
So it separates network control logic
from data forwarding that is hardware.
It enables dynamic configuration,
improved performance and centralized
visibility.
We have three SDN layers. First one is
the infrastructure layer also known as
the data plane. This layer includes the
network devices such as routers,
switches and data forwarded forwarding
processes. The control layer basically
determines traffic flow based on the
infrastructure status and application
needs. And the application layer
basically uh are the network services
and utilities that define network
requirements.
So some traffic terminologies that are
used in SDN north south traffic is
basically the traffic that flow between
external network that is internet and
internal network. So the north traffic
is basically the external or the
internet traffic and south is your
internal network traffic. East west
traffic basically flows within a data
center or internal network. This is the
traffic inside your own data center or
network. It does not leave your
organization.
SDN advantages include that it gives us
centralized control and simplified
management,
rapid adaptation to threats and network
changes and it gives us vendor
independent flexibility.
What are some risks of SDN? So
misconfiguration of SDN can cause
unintended
flows. Lack of universal standard.
There is a lack of universal standard in
SDN. Although open flow is a key open
standard.
So what is softwaredefined
security or SDS? So software manage
policydriven approach to security. It
integrates with softwaredefined
environments like SDN and enables
automated and dynamic security control
implementation.
Key components of SDS include network
segmentation, intrusion detection and
prevention, user device identification
and control. Benefits of SDS includes a
adoptable and
scalable security centralized policy
enforcement and better suited for
virtualized and dynamic infrastructure.
So our next topic is SD van or software
defined wired area network.
So some key characteristics of SD van
loads
that it has multiple connection support.
So it works with various van types like
internet, MLS or LTE. So for example, if
you have multiple carriers or multiple
connection coming inside your
organization, SD event supports these
multiple connection and can balance act
as a loan balancer between these
different carriers. Dynamic path
selection. So it optimizes and share
load across available vin connection
such as these. It gives a simplified
management. It provides a centralized
and userfriendly interface for
configuration
and it has the feature of integrated
security. So it supports VPN and third
party services for secure communication.
So so there was some uh issue with the
slide sequence. This would be the first
one but let's uh go through it now. So
it is the extension SD van is the
extension of SDN principle to van
environment. It enables centralized
softwarebased control over van
connectivity and management and it is
commonly used to connect data center
branch offices and cloud service
providers or CSP.
What is virtual extensible local area
network or VXLAN which is a feature or
terminology that is used inside SDN SD
van SD SDN and softwaredefined data
center. So VXLAN is a network
virtualization technology that extends
traditional VLAN capabilities.
It uses encapsulation tool wrap layer 2
Ethernet frames within a layer 4 UDP
datagramgrams.
So it enables large scale network
segmentation for cloud and multi-tenant
environments.
Key points in VXLAN include that it is
designed to overcome VLAN scalability
limits. So it supports up to 16 million
VXLANs per domain
while V has the limitation of 4094
VLANs numbers. So it is ideal for large
data centers and public cloud providers
and it provides flexible isolation and
traffic management across virtual
networks.
Now coming over to wireless networks. So
wireless networks removes the dependency
of physical cabling and enable flexible
and scalable connectivity.
Wireless networks are widely used in
homes, enterprises and internet of thing
environments. The growing internet of
thing demands drives continued wireless
expansion.
Some security consideration in wireless
networks include that wireless network
face same risk as wired network plus
unique vulnerabilities. So default
configuration often uh insecure for
example default
credentials like admin and password. So
the uh Wi-Fi router al
has the main vulnerability or security
challenge that when used with the
default credential or default
configuration these configuration are
insecure.
Unchanged default or lack of MFA
multiffactor authentication creates
major security risk. It is susceptible
to man-in-the-middle attacks, e dropping
and packer sensing via electromagnetic
signals. So wireless with denial of
attacks are increasing internet of thing
devices uses used bots in massive botn
nets.
So data einations from moving electrons
can be intercepted and reconstructed by
attackers. And modern attacks go beyond
wall driving. They involve discrete
Wi-Fi and cellular surveillance tools.
So key defense principle in wireless
network include to understand wireless
standards and protocols such as Wi-Fi
and Bluetooth implement secure
configuration and authentication for
wireless access points to conduct radio
frequency mapping and monitoring to
detect rogue and malicious activity and
apply defense in depth strategies for
internet of thing and wireless
infrastructure.
WiFi overview. So WiFi stands for
wireless fidelity and it is governed by
ITLE E 802.11
standards.
So each amendment in Wi-Fi improves the
speed, frequency use and efficiency.
802.11X
refers collectively to all Wi-Fi
version. not this it is not the same as
802.1x
which is portbased security or
authentication
in April 2020 2020 FCC decided and open
6 gahertz band leading to Wi-Fi 6A which
reduces signal interference
so these are the different WiFi
standards 802.11 standards you People
can pause the video and watch this. So
we have the standard name the frequency
used by that standard as we can see some
standard uses both 2.4 and 5 GHz their
speed we can see that speed is gradually
increasing the test is the 6 GHz and
their common name
Wi-Fi authentication and encryption. So
authentication methods methods include
open system authentication or OSA which
is no real authentication or encryption
and any compatible device can connect if
it is within the range of the Wi-Fi
signal. Shared key authentication or SKA
which requires authentication via a
shared key. It uses web or wide
equalence privacy WPA, WPA2 and WPA3 for
encryption.
Evolution of the Wii security. So first
Wi-Fi secret standard were wired
equivalent privacy or web which used RC4
stream cipher and static in
the original operated at the data link
and physical layers and it is now
vulnerable and can be cracked in matter
of minutes. So it is no longer secure
and must not be used. Next is the Wi-Fi
protected access or WPA. So it was uh an
interim replacement for web and it uses
leap and tkip for dynamic per packet
keys of 1 to8 bits. It introduces
message integrity check set of CRC
and it is vulnerable to brute force and
replay attacks and such as used in the
tools for WPATY
and GPU crackers.
Next is the WPA2
IE 802.11i.
So this one replaces WPA and uses AES
which is advanced encryption standard as
per FIPS 140-2 standard and PCMP.
So it has two modes WPA2 personal which
is passwordbased and WPA2 enterprises
the enterprise which uses a02.1x
network access control server for user
authentication
and again it is vulnerable to reshared
key theft and men in the middle attacks
which were discovered in 20
standards is WPA3 which were which was
released in 2018 is mandated battery for
new devices as of July 2020.
It gives us 192bit encryption and indiv
individualized
encryption per user. It mitigates weak
passwords and simplifies setup for
devices without screens and it is
recommended standard for modern
networks.
ILE E 802.1X
or post BA portbased network access
control. So 802.1x is a portbased
network access control or next standard
that provides authentication before
granting access to the network.
Its purpose is to ensure that only
authorized clients can connect to
network resources commonly used in
enterprise Wi-Fi.
And this is how it works. So it uses
three roles. First one is the supplicant
which is the client device requesting
access. Next is the authenticator which
is typically a network switch or
wireless access point. And last one is
the authentication server which is often
a radius or techx plus server verifying
the credential.
So integration IEA 802.1x supports EAP
which is extensible authentication
protocol for various authentication
methods like certificates, smart cards,
tokens and biometrics
and the use case is that it is commonly
used in WPA2 enterprise and WPA3
enterprise for secure enterprise wifi
authentication.
What is what is extensible
authentication protocol or a? So it is a
framework for authentication and not a
single method and it enables
compatibility with various
authentication technology. Over 40
technologies are supported. Common E
methods include ETLS which uses digital
certificates for strong security.
E TTLS which is tunnel authenticate
which tunnels authentication data.
E SIM or EI aka which is used for mobile
devices. LEIP is a Cisco proprietary
protocol but now it is inure
encapsulates E within TLS.
So note itself does not guarantee
security.
For example, if MD5 and LEAP are
vulnerable
when used with some secure protocol like
TTLS or TLS, it then shows the security.
Next one is the beep or protected e
which uses a TLS tunnel to protect
authentication data and it adds
encryption to e communications that are
otherwise unencrypted and it is common
in WPK2 enterprise environments.
Another one is the li which is
lightweight e and it is a sys propriety
method designed to improve tkip or web
security. It is vulnerable to password
cracking. For example, a sleep attack
tool.
It is deprecated and use. So li is
deprecated and should not be used.
Instead we should use pls.
So this is the tool that can be used to
crack the passwords in lie. The sleeve
attack tool.
Temporal key integrity protocol RTKIP.
It is designed as a temporary
replacement for web under WPA and uses
key mixing sequence counters to prevent
replay and a message integrity check. So
this one is also now obsolete and is
replaced by CCMP/
AES advancing standard counter mode with
cipher blockchaining message
authentication code protocol or CCMP.
CCMP uses AES 128 bit encryption and it
is standard for WPA2 and WPA3 wireless
security defined in 802.11i.
It is the preferred protocol. So no
successful attack against AES
has taken place up to date.
So how to secure wireless access points?
Number one is to conduct the side
survey. Side survey is conducted before
deployment to act to to assess existing
wireless signals and plan optimal
web or wireless access point placement.
So this helps detect rogue access points
and unauthorized devices connected to
the network is also used to optimize
coverage, reduce dead zone and prevent
overspill into public areas.
So the tools that can be used for side
survey are wireless scanners or wireless
intrusion detection system WIDS and the
purpose of side survey is to identify
document and cure authorized wireless
access points while minimizing
interference unauthorized coverage.
Number two is wireless access placement.
So best practices include to use central
location for better coverage. Provide
walls, metal surfaces and electrical
equipment which causes interference.
Position antennas correctly. So the
omnidirectional antennas are vertical
for all round coverage and directional
antennas are pointed towards the
intended area only. So tune the signal
strength to reduce leakage beyond the
intended period.
Number three is the antenna types. As we
study the omnidirectional antenna
radiates equally in all direction and is
common for office and home Wi-Fi.
Directional antenna focuses the signal
in one direction and is used for long
range or pointto-point links. So be
careful with directional antennas
because they can extend signal too far
getting potential attack exposure beyond
the required range.
Number four is the wireless channel. So
Wi-Fi uses frequency subdivisions called
channels. For example, 11 in US, 13 in
EU, 17 in Japan. So channels are chosen
to avoid interference and not for
security. General selection has no
impact on preventing spoofing or
jamming.
So number five is infrastructure versus
ad hoc mode inside wireless access
point. So infrastructure mode is
recommended which is where we have
centralized wireless access point and
they manage the clients easier to secure
and control. We have the variants
including the standalone wired
extension, enterprise extended and the
while the ad hoc mode include devices
that connect directly to each other. It
is less secure and lacks
control.
Number six is the service set identifier
or SSID. So it is the network name
identifying the wireless lane
and the types of SSID include E SSID
which is used in the structure mode and
BSSID which is used in A mode and it
uses access points MAC address. Security
practices while using the SSID names are
to change the default SSID names which
are the vendor defaults and they are
public and known
and to disable the SSID broadcast to
dehide the network which is a partial
security and combine SSID hiding with
WPA3 encryption for stronger protection.
Number seven is the captive portal. So
captive portals are common in public
Wi-Fi,
cafes, airports and hotels. So these
captive portal redirect user to login or
terms page before granting access.
Captive portals can include credentials,
requirement, payment or consent forms,
legal policies such as privacy and
acceptable use policies and if
compromise a captive porter can inject
malware or script. So it must be
regularly scanned and monitored.
Number eight is MAC filtering. So rest M
filtering restricts access to approved
devices MAC addresses only. Limitation
include they are hard to manage and
scale and they are vulnerable to MAC
address spoofing. Some access points
include anti- spoofing detection
features for added protection.
So now coming over to some wireless
attacks and first one is the jamming.
The signal jamming is overwhelming a
wireless access points with
interference. So legitimate traffic
fails. Goal is to disrupt or deny a
service or carry out the DOS attack. So
it is illegal in most regions but cheap
jammers are available online. Number two
is war driving which is actively
searching for Wi-Fi network usually from
a moving vehicle using scanning tools.
process is process of war driving is
that it detects wireless signals,
capture packers, identify hidden IDs, IP
addresses, max and authentication
protocol and attempts to crack the Wi-Fi
via tool like air crack or air not.
So our next wireless attack type is war
droning which is a modern variant of war
driving using drones to scan and attack
wireless networks remotely.
What are some motivation and data
sharing attack? So the intent is often
to get free internet or collect data for
later attacks.
Data sharing is that attackers publish
Wi-Fi maps with GPS data on sites like
Wiggle or Open B Map or Gina
Geomina.
So what are some legalities and ethical
perspective regarding the war droning
war driving? So legality is that it is
not explicit explicitly illegal in most
countries while ethically it is
controversial similarly to mapping
public data but may expose hidden or
private wireless access points.
LiFi or light fidelity. So it is a
wireless communication using visible
infrared or ultraviolet light instead of
radio waves.
And it has the security benefits that
light cannot pass through walls. So it
limits the signal exposure and improves
confidentiality. So the Wi-Fi signal can
pass through your building wall and can
be captured by someone beyond your
organization or beyond your building
boundaries. LiFi has the benefit that it
cannot pass through your building walls.
So it is 100 time faster than the
current Wi-Fi. So it is very fast and
speedy and the limitation is that it
requires line of sight and cannot
transmit through physical barriers such
as walls. So its status is that it is an
emerging technology with potential to
replace Wi-Fi in the future.
Bluetooth is the short range
pointto-point wireless communication
standard and it has a range of
approximately 30 foot and up to 300 ft
industrial
Bluetooth usage. It advantages are that
it has it does not require any base
station for operation. It has low power
consumption and ideal for mobile and
internet of thing devices. Disadvantages
include that its speed is slow. It is
slower than WiFi.
It interferes with the 2.4 GHz WiFi
frequency. It has weak encryption and is
vulnerable to attacks, for example,
bluejacking through snarfing.
So, the personal area networks or pens
are nonoutable and often unmonitored by
corporate security tools.
ZigGB is the low cost and low power low
bandwidth wireless standard based on ILE
E802.15.4.
It uses include the internet of in
internet of thing applications, home
automation, medical sensors, industrial
control and smart energy devices.
The security features of ZigGB include
the access control list or ACL frame
counters and 1 to8 bit AES in
weakness of ZigGB is that it is still
vulnerable to internet of thing based
exploits for example smart light bulb
attacks.
Cellular network. So definition of
cellular network is that the wireless
communication system divided into
geographic cells each with a base
station that is sell side acting as a
fixed transceiver
and it operates uh through mobile
devices that connect via specific radio
frequencies to cell sites or cell towers
enabling communication and internet
access.
It has multiple generations and they are
labeled by development phases. For
example, 3G, 4G and 5G and not by
frequency are power. So GR for
generation, third generation, fourth and
fifth generation.
So some generations of the silver
networks and their timeline and feature.
So the 3G was from 2020 2002 to 2005
and feature include graphics and
formatted text messages and it supported
picker switch data and has the speed of
2 Mbps.
4G was from 2010 up to present and it
has full unified messages messaging and
it supported native IPv6 and has a
greater speed of 1 GB per second.
5G was from 2018 up till now. It has
ultra high speeded, low latency and of
thing ination. Again, it has the native
IPv6 support and has the speed of 20
Gbit per second.
6G is expected to be released in 2030.
It will be AIdriven networks,
holographic communication and seamless
global coverage. It will have the native
IPv6 support and AI optimized protocol
and as it will have the projected speed
of 1 terabit per second.
So some security consideration of the
cellular network include expanded use.
So mod modern smartphone handle
application imaging v images videos and
sensitive data which increases the
exposure.
So cellular networks are not inherently
secure. So cellular transmissions can be
intercepted or spoofed by attackers. So
common attacks include rogue based
station, IMSI catchers, stingrays which
are used for man-in-the-middle attacks
and traffic capture.
The impact organization in on
organization include BYOD or bring your
own devices policies must address the
description of mobile traffic
application and data management and
network address network segmentation and
monitoring.
Our next topic is CDN's or content
distribution network. So a CDN or
content distribution or delivery network
is a geographically distributed system
of servers, proxies and data center
designed to deliver content efficiently
to users.
The key objectives of CDN include low
latency so they deliver content from the
nearest server to the user. They have
the higher performance so faster load
times for multimedia and web
application. High availability content
remains accessible even if one node goes
offline.
Advantages include improved performance.
So CDN reduces delay by serving data
closer to users. It has a greater
availability redundancy. The multiple
hosting nodes prevent single point of
failure.
Security and implication compliance
consideration of CDN include number one
is confidentiality risk. So content
spread across many servers may increase
exposure
and regulatory impact is that data may
cross international borders and must
comply with data protection license laws
in each jurisdiction. So legal
compliance include protect to legal
compliance is to protect licensed
content and ensure lawful content
distribution.
Common CDN providers include Akamayi,
Cloudflare, Azure CDN, Amjan Cloudfront,
Verizon and level three station.
So what are some secure network
components? So security professional
must understand how to securely operate
and maintain network hardware and
related components such as routers,
switches, firewalls and points.
So secure operation of network hardware.
Some secure network components such as
standards, policy and procedures. So
they establish secure configuration
baselines, management policies and
repeatable operational procedures.
Training is admins must receive initial
and periodic security training before
gaining device access management that
all configuration and patch changes must
be documented and approved through a
formal process.
Redundant power. So ensure power
redundancy through UPS or dual supply
for high availability network
infrastructure
monitoring is to continuously monitor
network devices for failures, anomalies
and security events. Warranty and
support. So maintain active vendor
warranties and access to technical
support for troubleshooting and
replacement.
So key networking terms include data
collision which occurs when two system
transmits data simultaneously corrupting
one or both transmissions. Broadcast
domain are logical group of devices that
receive broadcast at layer two that is
data link layer. Collision domain is
devices sharing the same transmission
where collision can occur.
The domain separations are collision
domains are separated by layer 2 or data
link or higher devices such as switches.
Broadcast domains are separated by layer
three network or higher devices such as
routers. So dividing domains improves
network efficiency and security.
Firewalls are used to control traffic
between network segments and enforce
security boundaries. So they can be
hardwarebased, softwarebased or hybrid
devices. So every packet entering or
leaving the network is infected and
filtered based on predefined rules. Core
functions of firewalls include traffic
filtering which which is blocking or
allowing packets based on IP address
ports and protocols.
Boundary protection is separation of
internal network from external or less
trusted one less trusted networks.
Logging and auditing records activity
for incident response forensics and
performance review. Fail behaviors is
should fail closed.
The devices or system should fail closed
blocking all traffic if it stops
functioning
properly.
The firewall logs are key events to
monitor reboot. Key events to monitor
through firewall logs include these that
is reboots or restart of the firewall,
failure to start or system crash,
configuration file changes, or rule
error during operation, force scan or
access probes and failed login attempts,
configuration and management. So
firewall must be manually configured so
they don't provide protection
automatically. Rules are defined in
access control list specifying the
authorized ports and protocols.
Permitted IP addresses are URLs and
allowed direction that is inbound,
outbound or both direction. Firewalls
require out ongoing patching and
upgrades controlled administrative
access and periodic rule review to
reduce human error and misconfiguration.
The limitation of firewall include that
firewall do not perform
authentification. They cannot protect
against internal that it behind the wall
threats. So relying on a single firewall
creates a single point of failure. So
they must be part of a layered security
or defense in depth approach or
strategy.
What are some types of firewalls? So
there are four primary firewall types
which are characterized by the OSI layer
where they operate. Additional modern
variation include next generation
multihome firewall. The number one type
of firewall is static packet filtering
firewall which operates at the OSI layer
three or network layer. It is also
called at the screening router. It
inspects each packet individually based
on predefined rules. So it pros are that
it is fast and simple and cons include
no authentication vulnerable to poofing.
Use case includes basic parameter
defense of the organization.
Number two is the application level
firewall which operates at the OSI layer
7 or application layer. It is also
called as proxy firewall
and application layer firewall deeply
inspects traffic to identify and control
specific application data. Pros include
high level filtering and it blocks
contents. Cons include slower due to
deep infection and use cases include
that it protects end user from external
network threats.
Number three is stateful inspection
firewall which operates at the layer
three and layer four or network and
transport layer of the OSI model and it
tracks connection states for example
three-way handshake of the TCP and apply
rules based on the context pros include
smart filtering good balance between
security and speed cons that more they
are more complex to configure
and resource they use more resources.
Use cases include enterprise parimeter
defense.
Number four is the circuit level
firewall which operates at the OSI layer
5 or session layer and it verifies TCP
handshake but does not inspect traffic.
Pros include it is it is efficient and
hides internal network details. Cons
include limited inspection capability.
Use cases include session validation and
network address translation environment.
Number five is the next generation
firewall or NG firewall which operates
at the multiple layers of the OSI and it
combines traditional firewall features
with the intrusion detection and
prevention system, deed packet
inspection, replication awareness. Pros
include comprehensive protection and
detection detecting the modern threats.
Cons are it is costly and those
intensive and use cases include modern
enterprise networks requiring advanced
threat prevention.
So what are the basin host or screened
host? So a basin host is a hardened
specialurpose computer placed in a DMZ
or demilitarized zone behind a core
router. It acts as a protective gateway
between a private network and untrusted
network like the internet.
Key features include it is also known as
the screen host or jump host or jump box
and its purpose is that it acts as a
proxy allowing external users controlled
access without exposing internal system.
It hires internal network identities and
limits direct connections from outsides.
Appreciation include that it runs only
minimal and essential services for
example proxy server SSH gateway to
reduce attack surface.
So security role of basin or screen host
include that it serves as the first line
of defense for inbound connection. It
insulates internal system. So if
compromised it limits attacker movement
within the network and it is commonly
used for administrative access or
controlled external communication.
So firewall deployment architecture
first one is the screen subnet
architecture. So a screen subnet combine
basin host to separate public and
private network segments. The public
segment is the segment where host where
we where which hosts accessible services
for example web or proxy servers.
Privates segment are the internal system
protected from the public access. So
this improves both security and network
performance.
Multi- firewall deployment is relying on
a single firewall is not recommended. So
multiple firewall are deployed at
different network tiers to increase
protection between subnets and external
networks and to provide defense in depth
and redundancy.
So modern cloud and virtual deployments
include virt cloud firewall for example
AWS security groups. So virtual as state
firewall for cloud instances for example
for Amazon EC2
and these cloud firewall control inbound
at outbound traffic within a virtual
private cloud or VPC. Firewall as a
service is the cloud delivered firewall
managed by the cloud service provider.
Benefits include automatic updates,
scalability and centralized management.
It requires strong trust and compliance
assurance with DSP
softwaredefined networking. So it is
flexible and programmable networking
that can dynamically adjust firewall
rules. Advantages include easier
automation and policy control and
challenges are in complexity
consistent security policy.
So secure network components
continuing with the repeaters
concentrators and amplifiers. So all
these components operate at layer 1 or
physical layer and their purpose is to
extend signal distance and strengthen
weak signals. So they connect system
within the same collision and broadcast
to main.
Hubs are also layer one devices known as
multiport heaters. So they function uh
their function is that they repeat the
inbound traffic to all the port. The
drawback is that no traffic filtering or
segmentation carried out by the hub. So
this is a security risk. So in modern
network it is replaced by switches due
to poor security and efficiency.
Bridges. So bridges operate at layer two
or data link layer. So they forward
traffic based on MAC addresses. So they
connect network using the same protocol
but different cabling or speeds.
So systems share a broadcast domain but
are in different collision domain. So
use spanning tree algorithm to prevent
broadcast loops.
Switches operate primarily at layer 2
but some at layer three also known as
layer three switches which has the
routing feature. Function of switches
include that they traffic only to
intended. They create separate collision
domain per port and they support vain
for broadcast domain segmentation.
The benefits of switches include that
they improve throughput and security by
isolating traffic through VLANs.
Routers operate at layer three or
network layer. So they connect different
network and route packets based on IP
addresses. So they either use static or
dynamic routing for example BGB, OPF and
RIP. So each side of a router has
different broadcast and vision domain.
So dynamic plus static routing together
gives us the best redundancy.
Gateways operate at layer 7 or
application layer and sometime at layer
six or presentation layer. Their
function is to connect networks using
different protocol that is protocol
translation also called as protocol
translators. So common type of gateways
include data mail application secure and
internet gateway. So they bridge between
on premises and cloud uh cloud networks.
Proxies is a type of gateway working as
a mediator filter or uh a cache. It
operates within the same protocol unlike
gateways and it is commonly used for net
or network address translation. They
helps anonymize traffic and protect
internal network structure and they uses
stock V5 protocol which supports
authentication.
Lane extenders are multi-layer switches
used to extend lane segments beyond
normal limits. They may acts as van
switch, router, repeater or amplifier
and they are useful for expanding lane
coverage while maintaining performance.
So wireless access points or webs
operates at layer 2 or data link layer
and they allow wireless devices such as
laptop, phone or tablets to connect to
wired or wireless network. So wireless
router role they acts as both a router
and a web inated networks and determine
the best pathway and destination for
packers. Frequency bands used by webs
include 2.4 GHz and 5 GHz dual and
multiband operation. Typical speeds of
webs include up to 300 Mbps on 2.4 4 GHz
and up to 450 Mbps on 5 GHz. So they
enable portable endpoints to access
network resources wirelessly.
Now coming over to transmission media.
So security of transmission area
includes protecting physical network
media in addition to devices and
software. So media connects network
nodes across lens and pins. The local
area network or LAN technology include
Ethernet IT 802.3
which is most common LAN technology
used at layer 1 and layer 2 and it uses
frame as protocol data unit and support
full duplex communication with twisted
pair cabling. Topologies include star
and bus and types include fast ethernet
that works at 100 Mbps and gigabit
Ethernet that works at 1 GB per second
while 10 GB Ethernet works at 10 GB per
second. So 8 bit is equal to one B and
80 Mbps is basically
10 mabit per
mega by per second. So 80 Mbps is
equal to 10 mAB/s when you divide 80 by
8 because
8 bits are equal to 1 by
uh studies the Wi-Fi standard. Now
coming over to the different networking
cabling type. So the wireless lane or
Wi-Fi has as we already studied two
modes infrastructure mode where devices
connect via wireless access points to
wired network while ad hoc mode is the
peer-to-peer device communication. It
can be between wireless access points
and must use encryption to due to open
sonic network. These are different
networking cabling types their speeds
distance they support electromagnetic
interference susceptibility and cost.
So these were the older uh standards and
these are the you can say the latest
standard and as we can see their speeds
are increasing as well as the can say
this. So for the most modern uh K 6 K 7
K 5 cable the maximum distance is up to
100 m and susceptibility is medium or
high and cost is somewhat me or high.
Optical fiber is different from all
these. It has a very high speed high
distance has no susceptibility to
electromagnetic interference. cost is
very high as compared to all other cable
types.
So the cable types include the coaxial
cable which is copper core which has
copper core with shielding and it resist
electromagnetic interference and
supports longer distances.
So this one is now largely replaced by
twisted pair due to cost and
flexibility. So the next cable type is
the twisted pair UTP which is unshielded
twisted pair or STP shielded twisted
pair. So these are four twisted wire
pairs which reduces cross talk and
electromagnetic interference. So STP or
shielded twisted pair is the metal foil
shielding and UTP is has no shielding
which is commonly used for Ethernet.
Fiber optic cable uses light pulses not
electricity and it is tapping and
interference. It has high speeded long
range but expensive and difficult to
solve.
So additional consideration of
transmission media media include 543
rule that is treat topology. This
topology we can have maximum we should
have recommended to have five segments
four repeaters and three populated
segments with devices. This arrangement
prevents sele signal attenuation and
bands
and maintains reliability.
So now coming over to network topology.
So topology is the structure and
arrangement of network nodes and
connection. Physical topology is the
actual layout of cable and devices while
logical topology is the how data flows
within the network. So there are four
main topology types including ring bus
star and mesh.
So our first topology type is the ring
topology. In this topology, devices form
a closed circular path and data travels
in one direction in the form of a you
can say a circle or a ring. A token is
passed between nodes. Only the node with
the token can send data. So there are
nodes. These are let's suppose nodes and
there is a token that is passed between
nodes and the node that has the token
can send the data. Failure of one node
can break the entire network. Since this
whole network is in the form of circle,
if one node fails, it means the entire
network fails. It is efficient for small
networks because no central server or
switch is needed. Dual ring design
prevents single point of failure. So we
have dual ring design. If one ring
failure fails, the nodes can still
communicate through the secondary ring.
Pros of this topology is that it is
simple. It has fast data transfer in
small setups. Con is that it is not
scalable. One node failure disrupt the
whole ring or the whole network. Next is
the bus topology where all nodes share a
single backbone known as the bus. Data
is sent to all devices and only the
intended recipient accepts it.
It has two types. First one is the
linear bus which has a single backbone.
The form of this such as this is the bus
or the backbone. Here we have the node
that are connected to this bus or
backbone. Then the tree bus which is the
backbone with branch segment. For
example, we can have a tree segment in
the form of a this where we have further
nodes connected to other segments as
well.
So it requires terminator at both ends.
Terminator means that it if it is the
bus we require terminator over here and
require terminator over here. Pros is
that it is low cost and easy to add
devices to this bus. You can easily add
devices and cons is that it has
collision since all the devices share
the single bus single media. There are
chances of data collision and single
failure breaks down the whole network.
So if this single cable breaks the whole
network you can say is broken down.
Next is the star topology where every
device connects to a central hub or a
switch. Failure of one link does not
affect others which gives us good
resiliency. It is common in modern
Ethernet networks and can logically
represent ring or bus using a hub or
MAU.
Pros of this topology is that it is easy
to troubleshoot and isolate faults is
because we have the central switch all
devices are connected to this switch.
So if there is issue let's suppose with
one device let's suppose there is issue
with this device we can isolate the
issue we can either see that issue is
with the cable or issue is with this
port. So issue can easily be isolated.
Con is that the hub switch is a single
point of failure. So if this switch
fails it means your whole network is
down.
Next is the mesh topology where devices
are interconnected via multiple
redundant links. Full mesh is where
every device connects to every other
device. For example, if we have three
devices
simple network, it means this one is
connected to this, this is to this to
this. If we have four, it means this
must be connected to each devices. So it
go gets complex when the devices number
increases because every device must be
directly connected to every other
devices. In partial mass only some
devices are interconnected. So for
example if we had for partial mess you
can this let go of this length. So these
devices are still connected to each
other. It offers maximum reliability but
high cost and complexity. As we can see
when the devices increases the
complexity and cost of connecting the
device to each device each other device
also increases.
Pros is that it is very fall tolerant
and resilient.
It is fall tolerant because if one link
breaks the devices can still connect to
each other through other redundant
links.
Cons is that it is very expensive
because we have very lots of link. Each
device is connected to each other. It is
complex to manage due to lots of
connectivity and redundant link and also
resource heavy.
So a comparison table of all the
topology. So the ring is the circular
loop. Resil resiliency is low to medium.
Scalability is low. Cost is low. Bus
topology is uh in the form of a single
backbone. Resiliency is low because if
the main bus breaks the whole network
breaks. Scalability is also low and cost
is also low because you just require a
single bus. T is the structure. It is in
the form of a central hub and switch.
Resilency is medium to high. Scalability
is high and cost is medium. Mesh is
fully interconnected. Resilency is very
high. Scalability is low to medium and
cost is very high.
So if people know the modern network all
network almost uses the star topology
because we no longer uses the ring bus
or mesh topology. We uses the switches
routers to connect the network.
Our next topic is network access control
or neck. So neck enforces security
policies across all users and devices
before granting or maintaining network
access.
Goals of network access control is to
mitigate nonzero day attacks
to authenticate and authorize network
connection
to apply role based access after
authentication to encrypt wired and
wireless traffic using 802.1x
that is elep
and MS chap to enforce page and
compliance requirements to control
access by device type and user role and
to enable
Identity based access management. So
next topic is the endpoint security.
So endpoint is the protection of all
endpoint devices for example desktops,
laptops, servers, mobile, internet of
thing, industrial control system and
robots from cyber threats through
monitoring, detection and response.
So why it is matter and why it matters?
So this prevents infected or
non-compliant devices from endangering
the network. It complements neck or
network access control
UEBA for stronger and layered security
and it is critical as attackers
increasingly steal valid credentials or
exploit remote access. UEIBA is a user
and behavior [clears throat]
analytics.
So key concepts in endpoint security
include the EDR which is endpoint
detection and response. So this
continuously monitors endpoint and
network events. EDR detects,
investigates and responds to suspicious
activities.
Defense in depth. So it integrates
endpoint protection with firewalls.
intrusion detection and prevention
system and proxies. Zero trust
integration means that you need to never
trust any device and always verify every
endpoint and user if even the endpoint
is your internal
uh trusted or local private device. Zero
trust mean that you should always every
time verify the identity of each and
every device. The endpoint controls
include local host firewall, advanced
threat protection, multiffactor
authentication, client-based ids and IPS
and continuous auditing
mobile security. So some risks to the
mobile security are loss and theft. So
due to small size and high data capacity
make mobile devices easy to lose and a
major data loss risk. Attack platforms
so infected or botnet control mobiles
can launch attacks. Personal ownership
so bring BYOD increases exposure to
untrusted or jailbroken devices.
Bed best practices include minimum data
retention. to keep only necessary data
and delete old information.
Authentication is to use strong
passwords biometrics and MFA or
multiffactor authentication. Encryption
is to enable full disk encryption for
example using AES 256. Integrity
checking is to verify devices status
that they are not rooted or jailbroken
before granting the network access.
management and policies regarding the
mobile devices security. So MDM is the
mobile device management which is which
gives us the centralized control
enforcement of security policies and
remotely wiping or deleting the data or
mobile devices. Containerization
is to isolate corporate data in
encrypted and managed containers.
BYOD and cope policy. So BYOD is bring
your own device which is employee owned
organization controlled via secure
containers
and hope is company owned
company owned but personally enabled
devices.
So according to NIST SP 800124 guidance
on secure mobile devices management and
authentication. So this publication
gives us guidance on secure mobile
device management and authentication.
Remote wipe is that authorized deletion
of data from lost or stolen devices.
Pure communication channels. First one
is the voice. So voice security concerns
include voice system which may be
digital or wiped that is voice or IP can
be intercepted, altered or hijacked. Key
security goals includes authentication
to prevent unauthorized interception or
impersonation.
Integrity to protect message and media
from tampering confidentiality
crypt wise data in transit.
So note end to end encryption is
limited. Some decryption may occur for
law enforcement compliance.
Number two is PBX and
parts security. So PBX is the private
branch exchange and parts is plain old
telephone service. So PBX are private
branch exchange which is enterprise
internal phone system. Vulnerabilities
in this system include default
configuration open ports and ports. A
risk that is posed by this system is the
tall fraud which is unauthorized premium
costs to the system. Controls include to
change the default configuration,
monitor bills, train users and use use
call monitoring tools.
Ports are plain old telephone services
or analog lines which are vulnerable to
tapping and use dropping. controls
include physical security, network
segregation and monitoring of legacy
system.
Number three is the w security. So w is
wise or IP network using TCP IP suit
threats to this wed caller ID spoofing
with through wishing that is wise
fishing and spit which is spam or
internet telephoning. Denial of service
attacks on WIP servers or phones. Many
in the middle attacks via spoofed
endpoints and unencrypted W traffic can
be decoded. Mitigation include to
encrypt W streams for example SRTP and
TLS and to strengthen authentication and
access controls and harden W servers and
monitor for anomalies.
Next is the multimedia collaboration. So
remote meeting security. So multimedia
collaboration include video
conferencing, chat, voice or IP, file
sharing and digital whiteboards.
Security risk arise from remote access
and lack of physical presence. Key
controls include that user should
require the authentication
for example pre-registration
uh before entering the conference and
using unique password. Use encryption
for voice, video and data transmission
and limit screen sharing and meeting
access to verified users.
Next is the zoom bombing. So zoom
bombing is the unauthorized intrusion
into video conferences which is was
common during covid 19. Attackers may
insert offensive or malicious content.
Prevention include to enable waiting
rooms and meeting passwords and restrict
screen sharing and guest access and to
update update the conferencing software
regularly.
Instant messaging security. So instant
messaging allows realtime text file
transfer and screen sharing often
through open ports for example port 80
or 443. Vulnerabilities include weak or
no authentication which can lead to
spoofing, lack of encryption can lead to
packet sniffing attack and file snare
pairing can increase the risk of malware
risk. So they are susceptible to social
engineering as well as well as the
stream which is uh inter uh uh instant
messaging spam. So controls include to
enforce authentication, encrypt instant
messaging, traffic and use endpoint
protection.
Number four is the email security
fundamentals. So use email uses SMTP,
POP 3 and IMAP which is critical for
communication but vulnerable. Common
threats include open relays, spam,
fishing, poofing, and controls include
strong authentication and delay
restriction, spam and malware filtering,
encryption such as TLS, SPM, and pretty
good privacy or PGP and user awareness
training.
So, email security standards and
protocol summary. So we have these
different standard and protocol that can
be used in security. These are their
purpose and these are the key features
are the encryption cryptographic
algorithm that are used by all these
standards
remote access. So how to remote secure
the remote access uh of systems? So
remote access enables employees to
connect from home, remote offices or
cloud platform. It is driven by
globalization, cloud computing and work
from anywhere trends. Remote access
parts include internet connection which
may be with or without VPN and it may be
thin client or terminal server access.
So remote access techniques include
excuse me the first one [clears throat]
is the server specific access which is
access to a single application like o or
time tracking and security concern with
this one is that it has limited scope
and lower risk.
Number second technique is the remote
control which is full desktop control
for example via RDP which is Microsoft
remote desktop protocol or through team
viewer and security concern may be the
brute force or credential theft. Next is
the screen scrapping which is the which
copies displayed data between
application and security concern include
the data leakage or unauorized access.
So remote access security risks remote
access basically expands attack surface
beyond physical boundaries and common
concerns include remote system may have
weak physical security
infrequent updates. So we may have
unpatched vulnerabilities infected
endpoints may introduce malware to the
system that is accessing the remote
system. So harder IT support and
troubleshooting troubleshooting the
remote system and give G give giving the
support is hard. So Wi-Fi use is
considered remote access even inside the
corporate premises.
So security control for remote access
include to implement strong or
multiffactor authentication, limit
access to essential user and devices to
encrypt communication using VPN, SSL,
TLS, SSH or IP sec and combine it with
endpoint protection and user and entity
behavior analytics. So remember VPN is
not total security endpoint hygiene
method. For example,
uh VPN is mainly for the transit packet
section. For example, if this is your
client,
this is your server. So your client is
in one country, server is another
country, you have the internet between.
So VPN is used to encrypt the traffic
between them. But you still need to
protect the server. You need to enable
its firewall. You need to have endpoint
detection and response. You have need to
have antimalware
and antivirus. Similarly, you need to
have all the security checking on this
client as well.
So what are some remote authentication
protocols? So these include the PP which
is basic password based authentication
and it is unencrypted and V connectnect
is chap which is challenge responsebased
authentication
and it protects protects against replay
attacks. Next is the e peep and lip
which are the framework for network
authentication. They supports
multiffactor authentication and
certificates. Next is the radius which
has the centralized authentication
server known as radius and it is common
for VPN and Wi-Fi. Next is the diameter
which is successor to the radius and it
adds reliability and it is used in
mobile networks. And last one is the
techx plus which separates
authentication, authorization and
accounting and it supports two factor
authentication used in Cisco networks.
So next topic is VPN or virtual private
network. So VPN is a secure
pointto-point communication tunnel or an
untrusted network. For example, the
internet. So internet is untrusted
because you never know where your packet
is passing through which IP ISP or
internet service provider is sniffing
your network. So VPN is therefore
important so that your data is encrypted
when it goes through the untrusted
network such as the internet. So it uses
encryption to protect data but
encryption is not required for it to be
considered a VPN.
So common uses of VPN include secure
communication between remote users and
corporate networks, intraet network data
protection, side to side connections
between private network, secure legacy
or secure legacy or risky application
and ensuring confidentiality and
integrity not availability. So VPN
ensures mainly confidentiality and
integrity.
So tunneling concept is that in tunnel
we encapsulate the packet inside another
protocol to protect them. This creates a
logical tunnel across untrusted networks
which is visible only to the tunnel
endpoints and it is used to bypass
firewalls or proxies when authorized.
Advantages of tunneling is that they are
secure and routable for nonoutable
protocols. The risks include that it is
hidden from security inspection. So
malware can be uh concealed inside the
VPN traffic. It increases the overhead
and bandwidth usage and it is
inefficient for broadcast traffic.
So some common VPN protocols include
PPTP which is pointto-point tunneling
protocol. It use it works at layer 2 of
the OSI layer. Yes, it has the
encryption but weak encryption. It is
derived from PPP and it supports chap
pap e and is vulnerable to men in the
middle attacks. Layer 2 tunneling
protocol again it works at layer 2. It
does not give encryption by itself but
it is often for encryption it is
combined with IPSAC and with IPSC it
gives both the encryption and
authentication. Next is the IPSAC which
works at layer three. It gives
encryption and it gives strong
encryption. It provides secure data
transfer with encryption and integrity.
Last one is the SSL/TLS.
It works at layer five and six of the
OSI layer and yes it gives encryption
and it is mainly used for web based VPNs
and remote access through browser.
So key notes of the VPN include that the
PPTP or point-to-point tunneling
protocol is legacy and insecure and it
should not be used for sensitive data
and environments.
So layer 2 tunneling protocol should be
used with IP sec for security. So it is
common modern combo for secure side to
side or remote access VPNs. So tunneling
increases security but reduces
visibility for monitoring tools.
Data communication is that data centers
and
data enters and leaves the network over
various communication parts. So common
frameworks include frame relay, ATM, MLS
and virtualized networks.
So frame relay is the van technology
using packet switching at layer 2. It
connects lens to vans via leans.
It uses virtual circuits not dedicated
links for efficiency and it has the
confidentiality risk. So you should use
VPN encryption over shared subjects.
Next is the ATM which is asynchronous
transfer mode. So it is a highspeed
layer 2 standard for voice and data. It
uses ATM switches for pointto-point
connection and does not do any routing.
It supports quality of service level.
CBR is the constant bit rate. VBR is the
variable bit rate. ABR is the minimum
guaranteed rate. And UBR uses remaining
bandwidth. So it is used over sonnet/
SDH backbone and supports up to 10 GB
per second speed.
Next is the MLS multi-protocol label
switching which combines the benefits of
ATM and frame relay. It provides high
speed and reliable packet switching
support traffic engineering and quality
of service. Virtualized circuits combine
hardware and software networking under
software control. It is managed
centrally. You do not need physical
presence and it enables SDN
softwaredefined networking
softwaredefined security and micro
segmentation for better control and
security.
The third party connectivity includes
internet service provider, cloud
provider, partners and vendors. So
always use SLA or service table
agreements to define and enforce
security expectations. Apply encryption,
access control and continuous monitoring
and ensure compliance with data
protection law for example sock to
reports.
So that's all for this domain. I uh got
through the domain very fast due to the
sheer and large number of slides but I
will share the slides in the video
description so that you can go through
at your own pace through the slides and
uh remember uh even if I went through
fast through the slides it is still
important that you go through these
slides and through this video
because if you are using any book I am
using I have uh the use the CBK
reference to prepare the slideshow if
you are using the let's suppose OSG
going through this will give you an
alternative perspective and will add to
your knowledge so please like subscribe
and share the video and we see you in
the next uh domain